all right so you each brought your own
version of stir-fry and you're going to
try each other's and rate each one out
of 10 and we'll find out which one is
the best sound good fantastic
hey i'm zakoon hey i'm leo hi i'm tom hi
i'm vanessa i'm originally from hong
kong born and raised moved to new york
city with my family when i was 10 years
old so i'm an immigrant first so i was
born in guangdong but i was only there
for like eight months and then i moved
to the us i was born and raised in new
york city queens new york flushing i was
actually born in sanghai actually when
came to canada when i was happier and
then the u.s like when i was four i feel
like a lot of dishes in the chinese
cuisine are stir fry in a way yeah i
just throw a bunch of stuff in the pot i
stir around
cheap chinese food i eat every single
day so i think i know a thing or two
about chinese food yeah you know how to
stir you know fry
stir fry
i actually don't really cook like you
know i was raising like ramen packets
like you know hot pockets so i'm like a
microwave chef
really yeah
so i made a kung pao chicken today i
made this dish because i grew up eating
it it's very relatively cheap and very
nutritious the main ingredient is
obviously chicken we have some roasted
peanuts in there some peppers some
spices garlic ginger and scallions you
know the holy trinity of chinese cuisine
but the thing that makes it special is
this cech peppercorns it gives it that
little kick what i did was actually put
it in some oil hot oil so it can steep
and let the flavors develop even more
and that's what makes this dish special
oh
it looks really good yeah it looks
really nice
this is kung pao chicken oh it's so good
actually it's great i just had like an
explosion of like a whole lot of spice
it's got some like nice red chocolate
peppers honestly i just don't like the
flavors of kung pao chicken in general
but i like this this is probably like
the most comfortable level of spice i
can take i think any more spicy i'm
gonna need like water or milk or
something you can taste the chicken it
tastes like the sauce like everything
like just blends in perfectly i just
don't know if i like the dish in general
though i'll give this a 7.5 out of 10.
yeah this is really good 8.5 it's all
very good 7 out 10 i think it's just
that i don't like the dish itself it's
very hard to make chicken tastes like
you know super flavorful yeah this guy
did a pretty good job
today i have a very classic chinese dish
tomato egg the dish is exactly how it
sounds like you know you got some eggs
you got tomatoes some sugar some salt
ketchup scallions this dish is actually
like you know one of my childhood
favorites you know my mom used to make
it a lot yeah so i hope everyone else
likes it this looks like tomato eggs
over rice this is actually one of my
favorite dishes curious to see if it's
like the sweet version or the salty
version this is one of my favorite
dishes growing up i don't know if you
would consider this stir-fry though just
because i'm thinking stir-fry you know
it's a lot of oily stuff
all that seasoning and soy sauce stuff
so i don't know
okay it's a salty version um that's not
what i expected it's kind of bland i
think it's okay it's good just missing a
little bit more seasoning more soy sauce
or sesame oil or something the eggs are
tender it's just those tomatoes are huge
chunks and they're not cooked down
properly i think it's too much tomatoes
it's kind of overpowering the eggs
there's just not that much sauce i feel
like i'm sorry i'm gonna have to give
this like a four out of ten but it looks
good though think of it like a six i'll
give it like six out of ten i think it
needs a little bit more salt more
seasoning uh texture's a little off but
all the ingredients are there
this is my attempt at chinese stir-fry
stir-fry to me is just something so
common in the chinese cuisine right like
this is basically a whole lot of
different veggies green beans broccoli
mushrooms and peppers and then of course
we gotta have some protein so i got some
chicken strips like chicken breasts in
there marinated with a lot of good stuff
soy sauce sesame oil garlic salt and for
my secret ingredient i decided to make a
little bit fancier or hopefully win some
points i added some caviar salmon caviar
over here on the side if they want to
add some more you can call them dragon
balls and of course presentation is
everything so i got the red plate and
also there's a little secret surprise
underneath the plate so make sure you
tell them to uh check what's underneath
there okay
what the hell is this wow
fancy what is this
smells weird i don't know what kind of
cabbie i've never actually never had
caviar so this is gonna be a first
experience for me
i have no words it was so salty
it's a very healthy dish vegetables are
a little too soft overcooked it just
tastes so weird it does have a lot of
flavor i don't know exactly what this is
but it's something i would eat if i
wanted to like cut down or be healthy
actually makes the chicken taste pretty
good yeah it's not as good as like the
first dish the kung pao chicken but it's
pretty good you know a bunch of meal
prep ingredients thrown in you know
stirred around and then this guy was
like oh [ __ ] i have this leftover salmon
roll from like my sushi lunch i'm just
adding to give it that wow factor i like
the caviar it's carrier you can't not
like caviar unless you're vegan i'll
give it one for effort and that's it i
gave it a 7 out of 10. the broccoli is a
little overcooked so it's like mushy i
like it kind of firm but that's just my
personal preference and the chicken is
kind of like in these large chunks and
it's chicken breast so it can get really
dry you know i would definitely eat this
every day you know it seems healthy too
so definitely six out of ten he told me
to tell you to look under the plate what
is this surprise
what
you know what it's actually pretty nice
like i give it a seven
ten out of ten all right dude you got 10
out of 10 man good job
so this is just like a classic chinese
stir fry there is lotus root whittier
fungus shrimp green onions carrot and
snap peas there's no secret sauce i just
put salt and sugar and like chicken
stock powder i don't know i just like
all these ingredients they're like
really simple and classic i just really
like lotus fruit especially like when
it's like thinly sliced it's just what
we eat like on new year's
very classic dish all right so this
looks really good i like the colors i
like all the different ingredients these
are ingredients that you know you have
to go out of your way to get i guess so
this person really put a lot of effort
through this and you know i i can
appreciate that
it's good it's like something my
grandmother would make oh it's pretty
good it's kind of sweet actually it's
really good you know like the the lotus
because it's not like a nice crunch snow
peas it's like nuts crunch as well the
shrimp is tender and it's pretty healthy
not a lot of sauces whatever but
everything works well together it's not
super oily for a stir-fried dish so i
really like that it only has that much
like seasoning like i said i don't think
there's not much soy sauce so it's not
super like salty i can only taste each
and every ingredient which i like
because you guys like you know a lot of
different flavors and all that it does
taste like something super homemade so i
really appreciate that seven and a half
yeah i'll give it nine out of ten it's
pretty good eight out of ten it's one of
the better dishes it actually beats out
like you know every single other dish
bugs the margin
all right so well done everyone i'm
going to read off each of your average
scores from everyone else okay okay okay
so there you are in fourth place we have
zakoon with a 5.3 in third place with an
average score of 7.7 we have tom
wait a minute
wait a minute second place with an
average score of 8.2 we have vanessa
that's pretty
and
good
first place with an average score of
nine we have leo i guess in the end
money talks and you know us asians we
love some enveloping the money baby and
you know the caviar certainly helped too
let's go
[Music]
you